What everything Muhammad said is
knowledge from God.
Oh, wow. And then that would that makes
it worse. Cuz so then if he's if this is
It's not worse. Yeah, cuz if this is
knowledge Where did he get the
knowledge? He got it from God.
Well, he's he's wrong though. If he's
wrong, then he didn't get it from God,
right? No, he got it from God.
Everything he said is from God and it's
Even if it's wrong? It's true. There's
nothing that he said that was wrong.
Everything he said is is true.
Sister, let's finish cuz this is the
important part right here. This is the
part right here.
What are you laughing at?
Yeah, yeah, I know I'm exposing myself.
I know I know I know. I'm exposing
myself.
I'm exposing myself. Watch this, guys. I
bet. So then it continues. Watch this.
Watch this. Let's see who's exposed.
When sperm are inside female bodies,
they can live for up to five days.
Mhm.
Mhm. Mhm.
Where's the laugh? No, read it out.
Yeah, but If what? If what?
Where's the laugh? I don't hear you
laughing. Why aren't you laughing?
Welcome to the panel. Thank you. And
then we have Ramadan coming soon. We're
preparing for it. Alhamdulillah. Are you
going to join us fast 30 days?
I'll I'll join you I'll join you I'll
join you during the feast part. Okay.
If you would join us in the like just
fast for 30 days, I think it's very
healthy and then You think it's healthy?
Yeah. You know Muslims gain more weight
during Ramadan. Yeah. You guys gain
weight during Ramadan because it's it's
actually not healthy. You guys stuff
yourselves. No, it's very healthy. Most
of the people I know they lose weight.
No, they don't. Believe me. I'm telling
you. I've been doing this since I was
little. I was born a Muslim. You're
you're you you guys literally act like
you're you know, not eating, but then
you splurge on food at the end of the
day to make up for all the food you
missed out on earlier. Exactly. That's
the way of worshipping and recognizing
That's not a fast. That's not fasting.
So what does the Quran say? What did
they say? What what does the Quran say?
I don't know. Will you tell me? I don't
know. Yeah, we should fast 30 days for
our during Ramadan. Okay, yeah, fast. So
why do you eat when you fast? So what is
fasting? Fasting is like fasting is like
you don't eat for the period for this
period of time and then you eat after
that period of time to respect the time,
right? It depends on the fast. You're
right. You can have a fast where you
abstain for a certain time. all your
life without eating? Is that what you're
saying? What I'm saying is is that it's
not really a fast because you guys you
would abstain for food for a certain
amount of hours, right? But then at the
end of the day, you stuff yourselves
with food because you're you're you're
not you're not denying your flesh.
You're not denying yourself really. Cuz
you're you're you're you're feeding it.
But yeah, so you're you're you're not
really like a fast is supposed to be
about denying your flesh and relying on
God and you know, and and things of this
nature, right? You guys you don't deny
your flesh. You you stuff it. No. So I'm
just asking you do you know can you tell
me the meaning of fasting? What is
fasting?
It's to abstain. It's to abstain. It's
to deny oneself and give yourself over
to to God and rely on God, you know, for
your me for your needs. That's that's
what fasting is. Okay. So fasting is
like the way I understand it like
fasting is like don't eat for this
period of time, this hours and then
after that period of then you can eat.
So that's a way of worshipping, right?
So when you go to school, so when you so
when you go to school, let's say you go
to college you go to college, right? So
you have four years to be in there.
After that period of time, then you
finish you take all your classes and
then you get all the credit and then
while you once you get all the credit,
then you are graduate, right? Then you
become a whatever whatever field major
you have. So that's the meaning of you
going to school to be in there for that
period of time. So exact just like I
just mentioned to you Ramadan fasting is
like you fast for that from Fajr time in
the morning and then you eat after
Maghrib or the time of Maghrib. The sun
is setting. Yeah, when the sun is
setting and then you guys go to sleep
with all that food in your guts and you
gain weight. This is why during Ramadan
statistically
Muslims gain weight. It's crazy. Well,
practically that I've seen people like
physical people actually my family,
myself, I have experienced all my life
people lose weight during Ramadan. I
don't know what you're saying. You might
be saying out of whatever research or
whatever school thing whatever. Maybe
somebody told you that, but I'm telling
you like based on experience and then
people that I've seen all my life
they're losing weight that period of
time. So it's part of worship I mean
worship. I know. So like pillars of
Islam, right?
So let me let me ask you. What why do
you why do you believe that Islam is
true? What what would you what would you
say is the best reason you personally
why you believe Islam is is the truth?
Okay, so let me like because I was born
in it and all my family are Muslims. So
let me keep that aside. Based on my own
understanding reason why I I I take
Islam as the best and the true religion,
right? So number one, the Quran. Yeah,
what about it?
Everything about it. Everything about
the Quran
Give me one. and how it came. By reading
it and the power of the Quran you know
that it's not the word of a man or
whatever.
you how do you how do you know that?
It's the word of God, right?
How do you how do you how do you know
that? That's what I'm asking. How do you
know when you read the Quran? How do you
know that it's
it. You feel the power. You see I just
read it this morning. While I was
reading it, just the power it made me
cry. Why am I crying? Why do you think
I'm just crying just like that? Just by
reading a book. So anytime yeah, anytime
I'm I'm reading it, I just cry. And not
me. Anyone that you see like most people
they cry and I don't know why, but it
just happened. So that tells me that All
right, let me it's very powerful in it
and it's not the word of God. Okay, I I
cry I cry I'm sorry. I mean the word of
God. Yeah, I I cry I cry when I read the
Bible and a lot of people cry when they
read the Bible. Some people cry when
they read the Book of Mormon. Have you
heard of the Book of Mormon before? The
Hadith? No. Well, you know, kind of, but
no. Muhammad? Yeah, no, the Book of
Mormon.
Oh, okay.
I thought you said the Book of Muhammad.
I didn't know. Have you have you heard
of the Book of Mormon before? I heard
about it, but I have
I have never read it before.
Okay. So yeah, the the Book of Mormon
supposedly came through a so-called
prophet named Joseph Smith in the 1800s.
I believe it was 1800s. And um
is it
is is is it based on Islam or
Christianity? Uh neither. It's a it's a
different religion. Okay. And so he
claims to be a prophet and claims that
God revealed to him the Book of Mormon.
And Mormons when they come they'll knock
on your door. They dress really nice.
They'll knock on your door and try to
give you the the message of the Book of
Mormon. And when you ask them how do you
know that the Book of Mormon is true?
And you know what they say? They say, I
prayed about it and I feel it in my
heart. I get this warm feeling about the
Book of Mormon and that's how I know
it's true. Well, that's their own
opinion. Well, yeah, that's that's what
they That's how they feel. So that's
their feelings. But but
You asked me my own like why do I
believe that it's true? Why do you
believe it's true? I'm telling you my
own opinion. You don't have to believe
what I'm saying, but that's my own
belief. I know. So what So basically
what I'm asking is if if I wanted to
find the truth, right? Not just feelings
because feelings people can feel
anything. How how can I determine who's
right out of you and out of that Mormon
who says the same thing that he or she
feels a good warm feeling and cries and
feels emotionally
connected with the Book of Mormon, you
know? Just like what you said about the
Quran. How do I determine who is who's
actually right though at the end of the
day? Evidence. Beautiful. There it is.
And that's So that's what I'm asking. So
what is the evidence that you have that
you've seen in your understanding that
you've seen that proves that the Quran
is actually from God? What's what's an
evidence that you can give me? So like I
said, but I'll say it again. I'll say
like three. I will give you three
evidences. Okay. Like the power of the
Quran, you know? And then number two,
everything that Muhammad came with is
true with no like if whatever he says he
he says in the he said in the Hadith and
whatever the Quran said, if you just try
if I just try it, I see that yes, it's
true. There is nothing that I that I see
in the Quran that I tried that is wrong.
All right. Now that
Yeah, that's another evidence.
All right. And then number three, how
the creation of Allah God, right? Mhm.
Everything he said or everything the
Quran says is true. Okay. I will still
go back to the number two like
everything the Quran says is true.
All right, beautiful. Yeah, I've tried
it. He asked us to um if we need
whatever, pray to him. He's going to
give it to and I've seen that. I don't
know about you guys Christians. I know
you guys pray to, but I mean I can only
talk about myself or my experience. I
don't know cuz I've never been to
Christianity stuff stuff. I got you. I
got you. So we got somewhere. So you
said, you know, the evidences one of the
one of the evidences is that everything
that Well, it's not really not evidence.
We got to check it, but one of the
reasons why you believe Islam is true
and the Quran is true is because
everything that Muhammad has said,
everything that Muhammad has said is
true. He never said anything false. It's
always true. It's always right on point,
on the money. It's true. So, okay. So,
let's let's see. I want to I want to
see. I want to I'm going to check this
out. If we were to investigate the
things that Muhammad said, let's see if
it's true. Let's Let's start with, for
example, you said the Hadith like we get
Muhammad's teachings in the Hadith. So,
here's a Hadith that I have and I'll
I'll share it on this I'll share it on
the screen so we can all see it. Give me
a second to pull this up for everyone.
Masha Allah Subhanahu Yahweh.
Alhamdulillah Yahweh. Let me pull this
up real quick.
Amen. Alhamdulillah Yahweh.
Allahu Akbar. Pretty soon, sister,
you'll be you know, Lord willing, you'll
be saying glory to
glory to God, the true God.
know what? Hey, you know what? And like
I've seen your videos and on YouTube and
everything and I have I have listened to
your live stuff. Yeah.
Like anytime I see you, I just have this
deep instinct that one day, I promise
that I I cannot promise, but I have a
feeling that one day you will come back
to Islam. Just like that. I don't know
why, but I just have that feeling. I'm
not trying to convince you or something.
I'm just telling you how I feel. No
worries. I I hear you. You know, I I
left Islam 2 seconds after I was born.
Exactly. Yeah. Yeah, you are right
because you was born I was I was I was
born a Muslim, but then I end up leaving
Islam.
Okay. That's okay. All right. You know,
just it just didn't it didn't resonate
with me when I was when I was an infant,
but That's okay. It's okay.
It happens. Okay, guys. So, here it is.
I'm going to share this Hadith. It's
Sahih Muslim 264 4.
Um
2644. Oh, this one? What does it say?
2644. Sorry. Okay. Can you just show it
to the screen so it can Yeah, I'm going
to pull it up for you. All right.
Before you uh before whatever you
looking, I can say something. I have it.
It's right here. So, another proof that
I can tell you why you was looking at
that I was just thinking. You see, all
the prophets that the Islam mentioned in
the Quran, they came with the same the
same message. I like that point as well.
Yeah. And with the same one message.
There was no or there is no any
different thing they were trying to tell
the people that they were sent. Okay.
And then if you check the Quran, too,
the Quran has never changed. Okay, see,
now we're getting stuff.
that Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
brought. Now we're getting stuff. So,
now we're getting stuff. That's good.
So, we got Maha Everything Muhammad said
is true. We got we got we got all the
prophets all the prophets spoke the same
message or came with the same message.
So, the Quran is in line with the
previous prophets and uh and what was
the last thing you said? And then the
Quran has never been changed. Okay,
good. So, now has changed many Okay.
Okay. Well, I was wondering about that
myself. I'm going to show I'm going to
show you I'm going to show you the Quran
been changed. I'm going to show you
that. But okay, look. So, let's read
this Hadith. So, it says this is Sahih
Muslim 2644. It says uh Hudhayfah
reported directly from Allah's messenger
that he said, "When a drop of semen
remains in the womb for 40 or 45 nights,
the angel comes and says, 'My Lord, will
he be good or evil?' And both these
things would be written." Okay. Then the
angel says, "My Lord, would he be male
or female?" And both these things are
written. And his deeds and actions, his
death, his livelihood, these are also
recorded. Then his document of destiny
is rolled and there is no addition to or
subtraction from it. Now, there's a lot
in this Hadith that I can touch on, but
I wanted to just talk on this specific
one right here. It says, "When the drop
of semen remains in the womb for 40 or
45 nights." Do you Do you know how long
semen lasts in the womb? Just continue
with reading whatever you saying. Well,
that's the that's the point I'm
bringing. Well, I know how many days it
stays like the Quran says. Yeah. No, no,
no. It says 40, right?
Well, I'm talking about it in reality in
reality. Yeah, so in here it says 40 to
4 or 45. So, up to 45 days or 45 nights,
Muhammad says that a semen remains in
the in the womb. Yeah, so if that Hadith
said 45, then yes, I believe 45. My
answer is 45. Yes. Okay. Well, that's
it's not true. Why is not true? Because
semen only lasts in the womb up to five
up to five days maximum. Okay, so that's
based on your knowledge. It's based on
science. No, exactly. That's what they
can see. That's what they can they can
only say what they can see. But he, God
up there, he know that it doesn't get
out of here there till 45 days. Well,
this is this is Muhammad saying this.
This is who? Muhammad. Muhammad said
this. What everything Muhammad said is
knowledge from God. Well, that would
that makes it worse. So, then if he's if
this is Yeah, cuz if this is not get the
knowledge, he got it from God. Well,
he's he's wrong, though. If he's wrong,
then he didn't get it from God, right?
No, he got it from God. Everything he
said is from God and Even if it's wrong?
It's true. There's nothing that he said
that was wrong. Everything he said is is
true. Sister, it this this literally is
factually incorrect. Factually, semen
cannot last in the womb for 40 days, let
alone 10. Yeah, 40 It says 40 or 45.
Yeah. So, That's what I just said that
the whatever science, whatever proven,
whatever, whatever, that's based on
their knowledge. That's what they can
see. But if they would go farther, like
check more and put the micro whatever in
there, they might see something over
there. Yeah, you know what they see?
What they see is is What they see is is
by the sixth day in the womb, semen is
gone. There is no semen. I don't know.
But whatever the Hadith said is the
truth, so. How do you know that? Because
that's my belief. Everything the the
Quran says and the Hadith said, I can't
argue with it and because it's just the
truth. Okay. I I see now. I see. Let me
Let me try something else with you.
Because I
I know Muhammad will never lie and has
never lied. This is He's lying right
here. No, he didn't lie. He didn't have
any proof came from whatever the
scientist was Apart from science? Can
you tell me based on you, your own
knowledge, that it stay there for 5
days? Yes, but based on the scientific
knowledge that we have, the factual
information that we have, see semen only
lasts semen only lasts. Exactly. Just
like you with the scientific whatever.
It's not what I believe. It's literally
it's literally we have tests. We
experiment and we have tests and then we
have the conclusion. The conclusion
based off of our experimentation and the
tests and what we observe is that semen
only lasts at 5 days. Okay, show me
something about what you saying. Okay,
good. And then will you believe it? I
mean, I don't have to, but I can listen
to you or I can just see what you show.
If you show me that, yes, I will
believe. Yeah.
Okay. All right, so let me show you.
Okay? All right, she says she may
believe it if if I show her what what
what what it says, man. How long does
semen By the way, I'm a fan of Kobe, so.
Nice. See, that's why we I knew we
connected. I knew we connected. How long
does this semen last in the womb? Okay.
So, why are you Googling it? Why are you
getting from the Google? This isn't
Google. Okay. I can go in there and
write whatever I want to write.
this is this isn't Google. This is Web
This is WebMD. This is WebMD. I can
write whatever they want. Medical
medically These are These are literally
doctors and professors, literally. How
How you know?
Medically reviewed by uh ooh, and guess
what? This person's a sheikh. Look.
Zilpa Zilpa Sheikh, MD. She's an MD. Her
name is Zilpa Sheikh. She's a sheikh,
y'all. I can go in there and act like or
just write it like maybe I'm a pastor or
whatever. Come on. So, see see you're
going to you're going to do that? And
then all people would Oh, yeah.
See what they say? But see see you're
you're going to you're going to do that.
You're going to just do that with
whatever I show you then, you know?
Yeah, just whatever. Just just show me
what you understand. Just show me the
proof. You prove it and then you you
bring the evidence whatever, then
definitely I'll I'll go with you saying.
All right. The answer depends on many
things, but the most important factor
where the sperm is located on a dry
surface Okay, that's Okay, read it
again. Read it again. The answer what?
The answer depends on many things. How
long does sperm live? But can I Can we
finish? But the most important factor is
where the sperm are located. Let's
finish. On a dry on a dry surface such
as clothing or bedding, sperm are dead
by the time I'm trying to read what he
said. I I've been pulling it up. What Am
I not Am I not reading? Why are you
What's going on here? Can I Can I
finish? Yeah. Okay. So, on a dry
surface, ladies and gentlemen, on a dry
surface, look at this. Oh, okay. Go
ahead. On a dry surface such as clothing
or bedding, sperm are dead by the time
the semen has dried. In water such as a
warm bath or hot tub, they'll likely
live longer because they thrive in warm,
wet places. Yeah. No, yeah, watch this.
Watch this. Watch this. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I know. I know. But the odds that
sperm in a tub of water will enter a
woman's body and cause them to get
pregnant are extremely low. Okay. Well,
let's go back to what you saying. Let's
finish cuz this is the important part
right here. This is the part right here.
What are you laughing at? You exposed
yourself. Oh, yeah, I know I'm exposing
myself. I know I know I know. I'm
exposing myself.
I'm exposing myself. Watch this, guys.
All right. So, then it continues. Watch
this. Watch this. Let's see who's
exposed. "When sperm are inside female
bodies, they can live for up to five
days."
Mhm.
Mhm. Mhm. Where's the laugh? No, read it
out. Yeah. If what? If what?
Where's the laugh? I don't hear you
laughing. Why aren't you laughing? Okay,
if but you're not done yet.
Okay, I'm not done yet. Oh, now now I'm
not done yet, y'all. If what? Read it
again. Yeah. If you're a man Read it
again. When sperm are inside female
bodies, they can live for up to 5 days.
5 days. That's the limit. Okay, thank
you. Then if what? If you're a man or a
person assigned Wow, a person assigned
male at birth and you have sex even a
few days before your partner ovulates,
there's a chance they may get pregnant.
So, sperm, semen only last up to 5 days
within inside of a woman. No, but you
you left something up there. What did I
leave out? I'll look at continuation.
Huh? You know what you the first the
first thing that you read up there,
that's where I want you to go back cuz
he's trying to run away from that part.
What am I trying to run away from? Up
there. Go up there. Right here? Yeah,
exactly. Okay.
stay longer. Is that a This is not
inside the womb. This is on a dry
surface and or or in warm water. They'll
live longer than they would in a dry on
dry surface, but they won't last days.
Okay, but I want you to go back where it
says that it may stay longer than that 5
days that you just made.
say that. It I think it's up there. I
think
It's right here. Look, the whole section
You're not listening.
Up up up up. The Going up doesn't It
doesn't help. We we we we read this.
This is where we read. How long does
sperm live? That was the the part that
we was reading. This is I have many gift
followers. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay,
go ahead. So, this doesn't help? This
doesn't help you?
two accounts. My other account I have
four four 488
What is What is this after? What are you
talking about? No, somebody is signing
in here right under the
No, forget the comment section. Focus on
this. So, yeah. So, so according to
this, right? Sperm and semen inside of a
woman last only up to 5 days. Okay, so
let me tell you something now. I'm very
sorry that I will go do my own research.
I'm not going to argue with you. Like I
said that I'm not going to It's your own
opinion or whatever you want to believe.
You have your belief. That's my belief
or my hadiths, right? I'll go do my own
research and I'll come back. Is that
okay
if you you promise? Yeah, I will I
promise you I will come back. But not
today. Not right now, but I will promise
you I will come back with more sources
and evidence from my books. Say wallahi.
Say wallahi. Wallahi tallahi, I will
come back. Inshallah. No, don't say
inshallah cuz when you say inshallah,
that means it never happens. Okay.
Wallahi, okay. I believe you. Okay. All
right. All right, take care. All right.
She was fun. She said wallahi. She
promised that she would come back, guys.
She said wallahi. She didn't say
inshallah. She said wallahi. She
promised. We know that when they say
inshallah, that means it'll never
happen. No Muslim that said that they'll
come back and said inshallah has ever
come back. No Muslim that said, "I will
give you the I'll get you the answer in
a minute. Inshallah. Just give me a
second. Inshallah." Never I never
received an answer that I was looking
for. So, I don't I don't accept
inshallahs. If you say insha Yeshua, I I
may trust it. If you say insha Yeshua,
then now you're talking. Now you're
talking.